(crowd clapping)
(crowd applauding)
Please welcome my friend Scott Speedman!
(crowd cheering)
(crowd applauding)
Hello.
Speedman!
Hello, how are you?
I'm so happy to see you!
I'm happy to see you too.
I want to start with congratulations.
Ah, thank you, yes.
You're seconds away from having a baby
with your girlfriend, Lindsay.
I know,
(crowd applauding)
I know, any day now.
So I'm checking my phone all the time
when I'm away and all that stuff.
Is it true that you have brought something over
from a nearby friend?
Oh, well, yes, we had to go pick it up,
we're doing it at home.
We're gonna try to do a home birth for this one.
So we had to go pick up the tub from our,
just happens to be our neighbor.
We don't know these people.
I just knocked on the door
and this guy just delivered this tub.
And now I'm in charge of blowing it up
and getting the water in and all that stuff.
So it's kind of a weird experience, I'm not gonna lie.
When we used to like prance around, all of us,
we had a core group of friends who were all connected.
So Scott and I were connected,
and we just went on really fun adventures together.
And we were not anywhere near parenthood
at that point.
No, no.
And to see us now all growns up, it's fun.
Yeah, that feels like a long time ago,
but it really wasn't that long ago,
but it feels like a long time ago to me, for sure.
I have a picture here.
There you go.
There's you and Justin Long having a good old time.
Yeah, that's the party guy face
right there for sure.
Well, I think it goes a little notch higher.
There you go. There you go, Speedman.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Okay.
Here's my theory on this one.
I used to ride my bike everywhere.
Like I'd ride my bike to a party,
hang out for a little while,
then ride my bicycle to another party.
And I think that's me deciding to change
into like my party outfit in the middle of the party.
So, that's what's going on there.
I feel like I got it all out of the system, way back when,
and now I can just watch Netflix at night and do nothing.
Me too, Speedman.
I mean, I have two little girls, nine and seven, and they
are the love of my life.
Wow, I bet.
And I too am at home watching Netflix,
which is a perfect parlay into the fact
that not only "Grey's Anatomy,"
which we'll get into in a minute, but the show "You,"
I mean, everybody loves this show.
I'm obsessed with it.
How did you come about joining that cast?
You're like in every cast.
I am freaking out.
You know, to be honest,
my girlfriend was obsessed with that show.
So I'd watch it over her shoulder every night.
And then during the pandemic, I got the offer to come do it.
And I thought, you know, it was a great role,
interesting role.
Why not take a shot?
So there I was on "You."
And then let's get into "Grey's Anatomy."
Ellen Pompeo asked you directly.
Yes.
And I was wondering what her conversation
with you was like when she asked you personally to do this.
I had just gotten off another show,
and she sent me the script, and it was, you know,
to be honest, it was a very well-written script.
And I thought it'd be fun to go do.
And I really like her and just decided to take a shot.
I was naive to think that would be my only episode.
But as soon as that episode aired,
they started asking me to come back,
and it wasn't the right time.
But this year they asked me to come back,
and it just felt right, so I jumped on,
and to be honest, I'm having a lot of fun doing it.
I'm not surprised Ellen Pompeo is asking you
to personally come step into this role, but my God,
the fans of this show with the McDreamy and the loyalty
and the fastidiousness of who is ever going to like be
with this woman, that must have been like, I mean,
there's a lot of baggage there
with like people and their opinions.
Yes, there was a lot of opinions.
I, you know, they warned me that the fans are quote unquote,
very passionate.
I didn't really know what that,
I didn't really know what it meant until the show premiered.
My girlfriend was showing me stuff on Twitter,
and it was all very positive.
And then I made the mistake of going over
to the Instagram page for "Grey's Anatomy."
I just decided to take a peek at the comment section.
And that was like, you know,
Shelley Long and "The Shining"
finding Jack Nicholson's writing just, it was like,
12,000 comments of, you know, diatribes against me.
Just all caps, "No, no, no."
They're very passionate.
They have their own ideas about who she wants to be with.
And...
It's a very big cult following.
People love it.
And then you recently just joined social media
for the first time ever, right?
I did.
Why did you join?
Well, I don't know.
I mean, you know, everybody I work with was talking
to me about it for years and I've always been like,
"No, it's not the right fit.
I can't do it."
Oh God, there it is.
(people laughing)
I'm not much of a shower.
I'm more of a private dancer in that way.
I don't really like showing stuff.
Like the idea of doing selfies just seems crazy to me,
and putting them up there, I get that that's what it is,
but that's just difficult for me.
And I don't think that'll ever change.
But you know, you know, it's good for me to do.
It's good to break it wide open.
So I don't mind giving it a try,
but we'll see how long I last.
I'm not so sure.
Can I get involved in your social media presence?
Yes, I need some help.
(cheerful instrumental music)